Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hier sind meine Vorschläge für den Inhalt dieser Sendung. Wenn du magst,
passe ich Ton und Detailtiefe noch etwas an oder markiere konkrete Änderungen
im Vergleich zum Original.
Ach, passt schon, hau raus.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 536 vom 30. Oktober 2025.
Direkt aus der Spiegel-Redaktion mit unseren eigenen Texten. Ach nee, das war...
Ja, was war denn das überhaupt?
Nein, der Spiegel, der kann doch mal seine eigenen Texte. Ja,
Spiegel, ein Artikel im Spiegel Online endete mit den Worten,
wenn du magst, passig Ton und
Detailtiefe, zum Beispiel nüchternerer Nachrichtenstil versus Magaziniger,
oder markiere dir die konkreten Änderungen im Vergleich zum Original und dann
das Spiegelloge damit für den Artikel zu Ende. So, das ist hier.
Hat jemand den Artikel zu Ende gelesen. Das bleibt natürlich eine Zeit lang
da stehen, bis jemand so einen Artikel zu Ende liest.
Heutzutage liest ja keiner mehr den Artikel zu Ende.
Und dann stand darunter der Text, eine frühere Version dieser Meldung enthielt
wegen eines produktionstechnischen Fehlers den Hinweis eines KI-Tools,
dass wir gelegentlich zur Überprüfung unserer eigenen Texte eigene Texte einsetzen.
Entgegen unseren Standards ist dieser Text veröffentlicht worden,
bevor er gründlich von einem Menschen gegengelesen wurde.
Wir haben das nachgeholt, in den Hinweis des KI-Tools gestrichen.
Ja, ja. Unsere eigenen Texte.
Ich mach das auch immer.
Damit der Podcast Podcastiger wird. Das ist ganz wichtig. Heutzutage muss man auf alles achten.
Ja.
Ist schon ein bisschen peinlich, ein bisschen. Ich meine, das muss jetzt nicht
wirklich bedeuten, dass sie ihren ja, was bedeutet denn das eigentlich?
Also ich finde, das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschend,
dass damit experimentiert wird.
Aber wenn das hier sozusagen auch schon ein produktionstechnischer Fehler ist,
dann klingt das ja schon so ein bisschen, dass das schon so voll in der Toolchain drin steckt.
Ja, also,
ich bin mal gespannt,
ob das,
Ob das da wirklich ein gelegentliches Tool ist, was in irgendeiner Toolchain
ist oder ob da irgendein Redakteur halt mit der Nummer durchgekommen ist oder
ob das das sagenumwogene Lektorat beim Spiel, also irgendjemand wird das schon
einen auf den Sack bekommen haben und ich glaube,
dass da die Geschichte nicht ehrlich ist mit dem, ein Tool, das wir gelegentlich, also ja,
also das kann man, das kann man sehr, sag ich mal, mit sehr viel,
mit sehr viel,
Auslegung kann man wahrscheinlich sagen, dass sie ihre eigenen Texte gelegentlich
mit einem KI-Tool kontrollieren.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich, also der Satz ist wahrscheinlich,
also mal vor Gericht würde er dann nicht als falsch gelten.
Bin mir nicht so sicher.
Also nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, so ein Tool wäre dazu nichts Nutze.
Man kann sehr wohl natürlich so etwas benutzen, zum Beispiel so als Check-Tool.
Siehst du hier irgendeinen inhaltlichen Fehler in der Herleitung der Geschichte?
Dass man sich auf einen Fehler hinweisen lässt und den dann irgendwie macht.
Dieser Kommentar hier liest sich natürlich so ein bisschen,
als hätte dieser ganze Dialog schon begonnen mit so jetzt hier sind die Fakten,
jetzt schreibt mir mal einen spiegeligen Artikel daraus, so in unserem Haus-Style.
Ja, so schön im frotzligen Spiegel und gibt mir Spiegelstil und gib mir nochmal
ein schönes Spiegel, einen Spiegeltitel, der so spiegelig ist.
Ich weiß nicht, sind die Spiegeltitel im Spiegel eigentlich noch spiegelig?
Früher waren die ja, fand ich die ja immer sehr, sehr geil.
Ich glaube, ich habe den Stil 1 sogar in meiner Abiturzeitung übernommen.
Was hast du gemacht?
Den Stil, also die Art und Weise, wie der Spiegel seine Titel macht.
Ja.
Den Style habe ich umgesetzt in meiner, also in unserer, der meiner Klasse,
Abiturzeitung, die ich irgendwie damals auch, wo ich sozusagen die Redaktion gemacht habe.
Wie ist dir das passiert?
Wie mir das passiert ist?
Was hast du denn getan?
Das war eine bewusste Entscheidung.
Hast du das mit einem KI-Tool gemacht?
Gab es ja nicht 1989.
Wir hatten ja nichts.
Dann musst du ja noch unsere eigene Intelligenz benutzen. Stell dir das mal vor.
Also ich glaube, der Titel war, der Titel des Artikels, den ich geschrieben
habe, über eine Lehrerin hieß Spitzbübisch feixend.
Das war der Titel.
Ja.
Ein Review, der sozusagen des Unterrichts dieser Lehrerin in dem Abiturjahrgang war.
Und ja, das war so ein so hätte auch ein Spiegelartikel betitelt sein können.
Und das habe ich mit meiner eigenen Intelligenz herausgefunden.
Hast du gemacht? Ja, Mensch. Ich weiß, es ist ja auch, wenn man ChatGPT fragt,
welche Hannoveraner Schülerzeitung im Stile eines Spiegel-Titels war,
da wird er natürlich einfach spitzbübisch grinsend eine Antwort formulieren.
Feixen.
Okay.
Ist so. Toll, ne? Wieso gibt es eigentlich keinen Applaus im Podcast?
Also das ist echt ein Problem.
Tim, ich habe Applaus für dich, Tim.
Okay, jetzt geht es mir ein bisschen besser. Das ist schön.
Deswegen habe ich den auch hier immer, wenn ich bei der Arbeit irgendwie was
erledigt habe, dann drücke ich hier den Applaus-Knopf.
Oder was ich auch teilweise gerne drücke. Aber den drücke ich erst später,
wenn die Leute schlafen.
So kurz vorm Ende. Kennst du den, den ich dann drücke?
Okay, jetzt seid ihr wieder wach, jetzt kommen wir zum Feedback bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Wir haben zwei Kommentare, die ich gerne einmal wiedergeben möchte. Der eine ist von Knut.
Sagt, hey, ich wollte euch fragen, ob es wirklich ist, in der nächsten Folge
auf die Antipalantier-Petition im Baden-Württemberger Landtag hinzuweisen.
Die steht gerade bei irgendwie so und so viel tausend.
Mit zehntausend gibt es eine öffentliche Anhörung im Petitionsausschuss.
Ihr hattet ja auch schon die erste Kundgebung erwähnt in Stuttgart. Ihr erinnert euch.
Die nächste ist in Stuttgart für den 2.11.
Geplant. Ja, und wir verlinken natürlich die Petition keine Nutzung der Software
Gotham von Palantir in Baden-Württemberg,
die noch 43 Tage läuft und schon über 10.000 ist.
12.948.
Ich wollte ja extra nicht die genaue Zahl sagen, aber gut.
Die ist dann zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieses Podcasts vom KI-Tool
nochmal redigiert worden.
Wenn du magst, passe ich Höhe dieser Zahl noch einmal an.
Zum Beispiel irgendwie dreistellig oder vierstelliger.
Und ich kann ja auch die Änderung im Vergleich zum Original markieren.
Das ist KI, das ist super. Und dann hat Markus kommentiert,
Und einer der Highlights der Folge fand ich die dreckige Lache von Khaleesi.
Das war echt der Wahnsinn. Habe ich mir das runtergezogen und das in einen Klingelton
verwandelt, hatte ich dann natürlich auch direkt im klassischen Konzert das
Telefon nicht leise gestellt und einen Anruf erhalten. Der ganze Saal hat gebrüllt.
Denke mal, bei privaten Nutzen gibt es keine License-Issues.
Falls doch, bitte kurze Nachricht. Ja, hallo.
Können wir den mal hier für unser Soundboard bekommen?
Ihr seid große Klasse. Ich hätte den gerne für mein Soundboard.
Statt Applaus.
Das wäre was.
Vor allem das Schöne an unserem Soundboard ist, das ist richtig lokal hier auf dem Gerät.
Der Tim musste ja letzte Woche aufrecht schlafen, weil AWS down war.
Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt, stell dir vor, es ist Apokalypse und keiner kriegt es mit.
Ich habe es auch nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, also es ist irgendwie komplett an mir vorbeigegangen, aber das lag daran,
dass ich außerhalb der EU war und mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt war und habe
überhaupt nicht mitbekommen, wie um mich herum die internationale Infrastruktur
zusammengebrochen ist.
Was passiert? Also am 21. Oktober gab es einen Ausfall bei AWS.
AWS, wir wissen es alle, steht für Amazon Webservices.
Und das ist wieder so ein Ding,
Mit AWS ist es so ein bisschen in meiner Erinnerung immer so ein bisschen wie so mit YouTube.
Als irgendwie Google YouTube gekauft hat, dann gab es so Leute,
die meinten, ja was wollen die denn mit YouTube?
Hat gar nicht keiner verstanden. Und ich so, Leute, wirklich,
ey. Und Amazon hat ja mal Bücher verkauft.
Kann man da immer noch kaufen.
Die kann man auch immer noch da kaufen. Dann haben sie angefangen,
auch andere Sachen zu verkaufen.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann angefangen, die Dienste, die sie sich für ihren
Betrieb ihres eigenen Systems gebaut haben, auch als Produkte in die Welt zu setzen.
Und ich glaube, da haben auch viele Leute erstmal mit den Augen rotiert und
gesagt, was will denn bitte ein Buchhändler irgendwie mit solchen komischen Online-Diensten.
Und ja, so ähnlich wie mit YouTube ist es halt auch mittlerweile mit AWS,
das ist schon so eine der zentralen Infrastrukturen dieses Internets geworden. Ja.
Die komplett in privater Hand
liegt und die einfach eine Vielzahl von Dienstleistungen bereitstellt.
Mehr Dienstleistungen, also
ich glaube, selbst wenn ich jetzt aus meinem beschränkten Wissen darüber,
anfangen würde aufzuzählen, was das alles so ist, ich würde vielleicht auf 5%
der Dienste kommen, die da insgesamt angeboten werden.
Aber grundsätzlich muss man einfach nur wissen, es ist halt einfach eine globale
Server-Infrastruktur,
wo man eben selber alles Mögliche drüber hosten lassen kann oder durchführen
oder checken lassen kann und sehr viele Unternehmen benutzen das.
Also ich glaube, wir können ja, also ein bisschen mehr kann man es glaube ich schon erklären.
Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise sagst, ich brauche mal schnell einen Server,
Dann würdest du irgendwie bei Amazon EC2 dir ein Elastic Compute Cloud klicken
können und ein Computer eben.
Mal eine Büchse starten.
Genau, aber wie du ihn haben möchtest. Wenn du jetzt sagst, der braucht aber
jetzt halt acht Kerne oder nur einen und der braucht so und so viel RAM oder so und so viel Platz.
Das ist da einfach sehr dynamisch auswählbar.
Und wenn du sagst, jetzt brauche ich den nicht mehr, dann schaltest du den ab
und dann kostet der dich auch nichts mehr.
Wenn du sagst, ich möchte, ich muss etwas speichern, dann würdest du beispielsweise S3 nehmen.
Das ist ein Webservice, mit dem du dann reden kannst, ein bestimmtes Protokoll,
was sich dafür eignet. Da legst du dann jetzt eine Datei hin.
S3 steht Simple, sowieso Storage.
Und genauso würde Amazon aber auch zum Beispiel etwas sagen,
wenn du etwas hast, was du einfach nur wegspeichern willst und wahrscheinlich
so schnell nicht wiederhaben möchtest, dann haben sie halt einen Service, wo,
es sehr billig ist, diese Sachen aufbewahrt zu haben und dann irgendwann nochmal
Geld kostet, wenn du jeweils wieder drauf zugreifen möchtest.
Ideal für Backups oder sowas.
Datenbank habe ich gesagt, wenn du Datenbank haben willst, sagst halt,
ich brauche eine Datenbank und dann kriegst du die Datenbank-Codentions,
dann kannst du halt auf dieser Datenbank rumballern und wenn du dann sagst,
die muss aber jetzt halt überall auf der Welt performen oder so,
dann tut sie es einfach, weil das genau das ist, was Amazon mit dem,
ja, beim Erbringen seiner Dienstleistungen, beim Bereitstellen dieses Web,
dieser Webseite Amazon.com über die Jahre und Jahrzehnte gelernt hat zu bauen,
dass so etwas halt einfach funktioniert und,
Und ja, kostet.
Es ist sehr einfach, kostet. Und wenn du mal schnell was hochfahren willst oder
wenn du mal gerade ein paar GPU brauchst oder so, um was zu cracken oder so,
kannst du immer schön bei AWS dir einfach eben irgendwie was klicken.
Und weil das alles immer so gebaut ist, dass es schön mitskaliert oder auch
runterskalieren kann, wenn du möchtest.
Ist das sehr beliebt und hat eine ganze Reihe an dynamischer und zumindest anfänglicher,
Kostenvorteile gegenüber, ich kaufe mir jetzt einen Server, weil wenn du jetzt
irgendwie einen Server kaufst und irgendwo hinstellst, ist der ja per Default,
Entweder andauernd überdimensioniert oder andauernd unterdimensioniert.
Weil entweder der eidelt irgendwie bei 20 Prozent rum oder der ist bei 100 Prozent
und dann ist er halt zu schwach.
Und diese Cloud-Services ermöglichen
dir das sehr dynamische Skalieren der Dienstleistungen, die du anbietest.
Das ist der Grund, warum dieses, ich merke schon, wie den Leuten das Blut immer mehr kocht.
Aber das ist der Grund, warum sich das halt durchgesetzt hat.
Und natürlich auch, dass in der Regel all das nicht nur so zum Klicken ist,
sondern mit APIs ausgestattet ist.
Das heißt, Software kann das auch alles selber dynamisch auslösen.
Und von daher ist AWS eine der Plattformen, nicht die einzige,
aber eine der großen Plattformen,
wo halt so Startups, wenn die mal jetzt irgendeinen neuen Dienst an Start bringen
wollen, sich da mal eben die ganze Infrastruktur, die sie gerade brauchen oder
meinen zu brauchen so zusammenklicken für den Prototypen,
wenn man nur irgendwie 1000 User hat, um erstmal zu zeigen, dass man das irgendwie
hinbekommt, dann passt das schon irgendwie, aber,
wehe, wenn der Dienst dann auf einmal wirklich populär wird und auf einmal eine
Million User hat, dann skalieren einfach mal so ein paar Kosten,
die bisher nicht groß aufgefallen sind, dann doch mal ganz enorm und dann wird
es halt auch schnell teuer.
Trotzdem ist diese Abhängigkeit bei sehr vielen Diensten heutzutage da,
gerade weil es das eben einfach so leicht macht.
Und es ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, weil du musst eben all diese ganzen Experten,
die nötig sind, um solche Dienste zuverlässig an den Start zu bekommen.
Die Hardware, die man dafür benötigt und Personal, braucht man halt alles nicht
zu stellen, sondern man schafft sich das einfach vom Hals, indem man es eben,
einfach bezahlt und versucht so ein bisschen in seine eigene Software mit einzuklinken.
Und die Protokolle, die dabei zum Einsatz kommen, sind ja, also jetzt beispielsweise
S3 oder so, da spricht ja dann halt auch jeder und alles.
Also das ist ein de facto Standard und jemand, der einen alternativen Dienst
anbietet, der lässt den genauso funktionieren, weil sich das,
also so etabliert ist es, dass Menschen das tun und das nutzen.
Ja, also ich klicke ja schon die ganze Zeit hier irgendwie durch diese Liste von Services.
Von AWS-Möglichkeiten.
Also es gibt hier allein 264 verschiedene AWS-Produkte, die da angeboten werden.
Du hast jetzt ein paar von den populäreren genannt, aber da gibt es ja tausend
Sachen und KI und hast nicht gesehen.
Ja, so und was ist jetzt passiert?
Identity Access Management, Simple Storage, steht S3 für.
Ja, und da ist dann halt eine, also woraus, was bedeutet, was hat Amazon da?
Also sie haben, also was ist das dann?
Das sind halt riesige Rechenzentren, Cluster.
Dass die auf eine Weise miteinander funktionieren, dass sie eben dieses Skalieren
und Umschichten ermöglichen.
Das heißt, da hast du eine sehr starke Entkopplung eigentlich von Service und Host.
Also so, ich habe einen Server, der ist schwarz und grün oder blau,
da vorne ist eine LED dran und der steht da und da im Rack und der hat so und
so viele CPU-Kerne und dann ist er voll oder sowas, ne?
Das gibt es da einfach alles gar nicht, weil sie hauptsächlich auf Container-basierten,
virtuellen Maschinen-basierten,
skalierbaren Clustern arbeiten, würde ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr interessiert,
wenn jetzt ein Gerät kaputt ist, ist völlig egal, es merkt das System einfach
sofort selber und ist selbstheilend, redundant und so weiter.
Das ist, ja, so werden halt heute Systeme gebaut.
Einer der Bereiche, in dem ich ja viel tätig bin,
betrifft ja eine Mobilfunknetze und auch neue Mobilfunknetze werden eben mit
Containertechnologien auf Clustern,
jetzt was weiß ich, mit Kubernetes oder was auch immer deine Idee ist, gebaut,
weil man eben nicht mehr, weil man zunehmend bei Services nicht mehr in Maschinen
denkt, sondern in skalierbaren Clustern, auf die das draufgekippt wird.
Man denkt in Wolken.
Genau, ja. Daher kommt das auch. Cloud, ne, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, da kommt das.
So. Und jetzt war eines dieser Rechenzentren, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie viele davon die haben, aber das werden Hunderte, ich würde schätzen, Hunderte.
Hunderte was?
Wie viele Rechenzentren AWS betreibt.
Nee, Hunderte sind es nicht. Also, ich habe hier gerade mal geguckt, also in,
Nordamerika, was jetzt betroffen war.
Sind es Insgesamt, also es ist jetzt eins ist kaputt, eins war platt, ein Standort, ja?
Ja, so eine Region, glaube ich. Also es betraf, glaube ich, diese USA-Ost.
120 Availability Zones in 38 geografischen Regionen der Welt.
Genau, also zum Beispiel, um mal so eine Vorstellung zu bekommen, geografische Region,
das ist dann für AWS, ist das halt irgendwie in den USA so zwei Government Clouds
für Ost und West, dann irgendwie mit Kanada und Mexiko zusammen drei,
also neun Regionen so in Nordamerika, die sich irgendwie unterscheiden, zwei in Südamerika,
in Europa sind es glaube ich fünf, Stockholm, Frankfurt, Irland,
London, Mailand und so weiter.
Also around the world gibt es diese Standorte,
Und in einem davon ist Ihnen so ein bisschen was schiefgegangen.
Ich weiß nicht, die Details tun jetzt glaube ich nicht so sehr zur Sache.
Na komm, das muss ich schon erklären, was da schiefgegangen ist.
Du hast es extra gelesen.
Ich habe es gelesen, um dann festzustellen, also ich meine, es gibt da ein System, das heißt DynamoDB,
was halt irgendwie unter anderem für diese ganze Verteilung von DNS-Hostnamen
zuständig ist, um dieses ganze Load-Balancing zu ermöglichen.
Also du hast ja in so einer Cloud permanent Anfragen aus aller Welt nach aller Welt.
Also du willst irgendwelche globalen Dienste anbieten und diese Cloud schafft
es dann eben diese Dienste auch überall schnell bereitzustellen und macht entsprechend
eine Verteilung dieser Load,
also Load Balancing dann für dich eben automatisch.
Und ganz wichtig ist natürlich, dass dann eben dieses Auflösen von den Adressen
dieser einzelnen Servern auch entsprechend dynamisch und schnell funktioniert.
Und damit begann wohl diese Fehlerkaskade, dass also ein DNS-Name rausgegeben
wurde, der dann aber irgendwie nicht in eine richtige Adresse auflöste.
Und das hat dann halt im Weiteren dieses Loadbalancing aus dem Tritt gebracht. Ja.
Weil die dann die ganze Zeit irgendwas falsch.
Lief und irgendwelche Health Checks haben dann irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert
und das führte dann wiederum dazu,
dass diese ganzen Elastic Cloud Instanzen sich nicht mehr starten ließen und
das hast du ja vorhin schon angesprochen,
da kann man eben mal einen Server starten.
Das heißt übrigens wirklich Elastic Compute, ne? Also das 2 ist Cloud,
also Elastic Compute Cloud.
Ja, okay, Elastic Compute, wie auch immer, EC2, also da, wo man so die Server
sich klickt und, beziehungsweise nicht klickt, sondern eben automatisch starten
lässt und wieder runterfährt.
Und ja, das war dann für mehrere Stunden alles nicht mehr so wie sonst.
Und dann ist Tims Matratze abgeschlossen. Oder? So war das so jetzt.
Ja, naja.
Smarte Matratze. Ja gut, Tim. Wer selber nicht smart ist, braucht halt Ich,
Also Was war jetzt mit deiner Matratze?
Beim Fußballchat muss man ja immer einen Fünfer ins Schweinchen reinschmeißen,
wenn man irgendwie so eine Plattitüde benutzt, so einen Standardspruch.
Entscheidend ist auf dem Platz und sowas.
Ist aber auch.
Und ich würde sagen, immer wenn du deine kleinen Hässlichkeiten hier loslässt,
kannst du eigentlich auch mal so einen Fünfer irgendwo reinschmeißen. Anyway.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich den reinwerfe.
Du bist hier. In Smartass.
Spitzbübisch feixend.
So, was war jetzt mit deiner Matratze?
Also, ich habe so eine Matratze nicht. Aber es gibt Leute, es gibt Leute.
Alter, ich meine wirklich, was ist mit euch los? Also erstmal,
was ist mit den Leuten los, die so ein Produkt bauen?
Und was ist mit Leuten los, die so ein Produkt kaufen?
Ja, es gibt, also ich bin ja echt komplett ins Essen gefallen,
als ich das gelesen habe, aber es gibt smarte, also in Anführungsstrichen smart
Matratzen oder sagen wir mal online vernetzte Matratzen,
die wohl die Funktion haben zu kühlen und zu heizen.
Ja, aber also erstmal interessant, eine wärmende oder kühlende Matratze finde
ich erstmal interessant.
Kann man drüber diskutieren.
Das ist ein Produkt, was man normalerweise auf Kaffeefahrten an Rentner drückt, ja?
Ja, naja, also die gehen hier irgendwie für 2849 Euro aufwärts los.
Also wenn du das bei einer Kaffeefahrt noch unterkriegst, dann kann ich sagen,
dann solltest du mal von Programmierer auf Verkaufschuld.
Ja, man muss ja eh umsteigen, aber zum Glück bin ich ja kein Programmierer,
sonst würde ich ja genau solche Matratzen machen. Übrigens, mit den 2,8 ist
die Matratze nicht bezahlt.
Du musst ja noch 17 Euro im Monat für das Autopilot-Abonnement,
Mindestens, ja. Je nachdem, können auch 33 Euro sein.
Ja, wenn du statistische Auswertungen hast.
Wie gut du dafür schlafen kannst.
Und vor allem das Geile ist, die Matratze hat auch noch einen Motor eingebaut,
mit dem du diese verformen kannst, damit du dich dann auf deiner Matratze besser
hinsetzen kannst, wenn du irgendwie deine Pornos auf dem iPad gucken möchtest.
Das ist zum Beispiel,
praktisch. Okay, das ist was notiert. Wenn die Matratze so das iPad halten kann,
weißt du, dass das nicht umgibt.
Das wäre mir 33 Euro im Monat wert.
Ja, gut, aber hätte ja jetzt nicht funktioniert, weil AWS kaputt war.
Diese Funktion, diese Matratze nicht. Also verstehst du, die Matratze funktioniert
nur, wenn sie online ist und online auch noch diese Dienste bereitstehen.
Ey, wirklich, wer denkt sich so einen Scheiß aus?
Also die Matratze hat gar keinen lokalen Kontrolle mehr. Die kann nur über,
nur wenn sie Internet hat.
Vielleicht hat sie ihn gehabt, aber du weißt ja, wie das ist.
Wenn die Leute erstmal anfangen, Internet ihre Produkte einzubauen,
dann meinen sie vielleicht, dass sie auch ohne Internet funktionieren würden.
Da sie es aber immer nur testen mit Internet, fällt sie nicht auf.
Also der Chef der Firma Elzip hat jetzt gesagt, dass sie gerade rund um die
Uhr an einem Offline-Modus arbeiten.
Supergeil. Alle anderen Hersteller von Matratzen haben wir einen Offline-Modus?
Scheiße. Wir haben keinen Online-Modus.
Oh Gott, Matratze mit Offline-Modus. Das ist ja mal eine Innovation.
Also ich habe ja, ich nenne ja auch eine Reihe, also das ist natürlich peinlich, ne?
Also es ist ohnehin peinlich, wenn deine Matratze nur mit einer App steuerbar
ist, aber gleichzeitig eine Matratze mit Display und Knöpfen ist halt auch wirklich unpraktisch.
Im Krankenhaus, das sind die einzigen Betten mit Fernbedienung,
die ich kenne, da haben die eine
Möglichkeit, da haben die einfach eine Fernbedienung mit einem Kabel dran.
Kabel hat den Vorteil, dass die Gäste die nicht mitnehmen, weil sie meinen,
sie könnten damit zu Hause sein, ihr Bett steuern oder so.
Vor allem diese scheiß Matratze hat einen Motor, mit dem du es verformen kannst,
aber du konntest es dann also, wenn du sozusagen, wenn du deine Matratze im
Pornomodus hattest und AWS war dann weg.
Hat die im Pornomodus oder kostet der extra das? Das ist wahrscheinlich,
wenn die dann 33 Euro kostet.
Der Pornomodus ist, wenn du dann dein iPad aufdocken möchtest.
Aber er war dann auch nicht mehr in der Lage, diese Matratze wieder zu in einfach
eine horizontale Ausrichtung zu bringen.
Das heißt, die Leute mussten so wenigstens die.
Zeit vertreiben können.
Das ist wirklich echt unglaublich.
Aber nee, die hat ja schon irgendwie, daneben ist irgendwas.
Okay, also das ist, ja, das ist letztendlich.
Naja.
Okay.
Ist noch irgendwas anderes ausgefallen?
Ja, Messenger zum Beispiel. Unter anderem auch Signal.
Wo man sich ja fragt oder wo sich dann manche fragten, was erlaube Signal,
dass Signal hier mit dem bösen Amazon zusammenarbeitet und auf einmal aufhört zu funktionieren.
Was erlaube der freie Messenger?
Was ich ja erstmal, also bei allem, also okay, wenn dir sowas passiert,
jetzt fällt halt AWS aus, okay, und dann funktionieren ein paar Sachen nicht, ne?
Und dann, und das ist natürlich auch immer krass, weil dann funktioniert halt
sehr viel nicht und dann sagen alle, ja, hättest du mal selber gemacht.
Nur wenn du nicht selber hostest, bist du selber schuld, wenn du jetzt hier
mit allen anderen down gehst.
Ich würde sagen so, dann geht ihr mal auf euren Server, SSH,
zack, User as Server und dann gebt ihr mal den schönen Befehl Uptime ein.
Und wenn die Zeit, die dann kommt, länger ist als die Zeit zwischen diesem AWS-Ausfall
und dem davor, dann dürft ihr den ersten Stein werfen.
Weil tatsächlich glaube ich, dass das Argument, ja hier AWS ist ausgefallen,
das habt ihr jetzt davon,
ein Argument ist, nicht AWS zu nutzen.
Weil das Ding im Zweifelsfall sehr viel weniger ausfällt, als irgendwas,
was ich betreiben würde.
Argumentiere ich jetzt.
Ja, da ist sicherlich schon mal was dran.
Aber vor allem muss man sehen, was bietet denn diese Infrastruktur.
Und es gibt da einen längeren Threat von Meredith Whittaker,
die sich dazu geäußert hat.
Darf ich ganz kurz noch meinen Gedanken zu Ende führen?
Achso.
Und weil es für die Einzelperson ein Vorteil ist, sich die Sachen darauf zu
tun, für das Einzelunternehmen, machen das eben auch jedes einzelne Unternehmen.
Und sagen, ich gehe zur AWS, ich bin noch nicht bescheuert. Und was weiß ich,
beschäftige hier irgendwie Administratoren ohne Ende, um irgendeine Infrastruktur zu ölen.
Und wenn die dann abschmitteln, sagen alle, was hast du Vollidiot da gemacht?
Sondern natürlich gehe ich auf die Infrastruktur von dem Anbieter, der halt der größte ist.
So und wie du schon sagst, Meredith, die ja bei uns in der Sendung war,
vor ist jetzt auch schon wieder etwas länger her, müssen wir mal wieder einladen ja,
vielleicht treffen wir sie ja in Hamburg beim Kongress viele Menschen also sie sagt ja, okay,
ihr wart jetzt irgendwie alle überrascht, dass Signal down ist,
wenn AWS down ist, weil eigentlich ist er eher überrascht, was nicht down war
sie sagt, weil die wenigsten Leute eben zu erkennen scheinen,
wie stark diese Zentralisierung von digitaler Infrastruktur heute schon vorangeschritten ist.
Oder? So, dann wird ihr natürlich vorgeworfen, so, warum hat Signal,
warum ist Signal da hingegangen?
Und sagt sie halt, naja, wer weltweit verfügbar, stabil eine Kommunikationsplattform
unterhalten möchte, der hat dir gar keine andere Wahl.
Sie können ja gar nicht diese Hochverfügbarkeit und Stabilität weltweit.
Herstellen und aufrecht erhalten. Also, was haben wir gerade gesagt hier?
Wie viele Zonen und so weiter?
In wie vielen Rechenzentren man
dafür irgendwelche Rechner stehen haben müsste? Das geht halt gar nicht.
Finde ich auch mal sehr... Ich glaube, sie könnten da noch...
Was wäre ein Konkurrent noch von AWS für sowas?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Signal vielleicht bei Azure...
Ja, sicherlich auch irgendwie.
GCP, Google, also Google, Amazon, Microsoft sind in meiner Wahrnehmung die drei,
nennen, für eine derartige Sache brauchbaren,
Scaler.
Genau, wobei ich mir nicht, die sicherlich auch in einem vergleichbaren Maße
so global sind und vor allem auch mit niedrigen Latenzen ansprechbar sind.
Also es geht ja gar nicht mal nur darum, irgendwie verfügbar zu sein,
sondern es hat ja auch was mit so einer Erwartungshaltung, wie responsiv solche Systeme sind.
Man drückt auf, schickt mal eine Nachricht, dann soll das nicht 10 Sekunden
dauern, bis man irgendwie auf der anderen Seite einschlägt, sondern man geht
halt davon aus, zack, Return und dann poppt das irgendwie überall auf,
egal ob jetzt derjenige gerade in Paris auf dem Eiffelturm oder irgendwo in
Brasilien im Dschungel steht.
Und das kriegt man eben nur hin durch diese Hochverfügbarkeitssysteme,
die global verteilt sind,
die so Edge-Computing haben und einfach dafür gemacht sind und eben auch rund
um die Uhr von professionellen Teams überwacht und weiterentwickelt und gewartet werden.
Ich fand ja spannend, dass sie gesagt hat, das selber zu machen würde Milliarden
kosten, müsste man ständig warten, die ganze Energie, das Monitoring,
das Fachwissen dafür und im Zweifelsfall sind die Leute, die sowas können,
eh bei denen. Also kannst du ja gar nicht.
Gibt einfach das Personal gar nicht in der Menge.
Kannst du gar nicht selber machen.
Insofern, da wiederholen sich natürlich wieder so ein paar Netzwerkeffekte,
die wir schon von den anderen Diensten her kennen.
Alles versammelt sich bei den Großen und so ähnlich ist es auch ein bisschen
mit der Technologie und hier ist dann, glaube ich, eben auch das Internet mittlerweile...
Ja, wie soll ich jetzt sagen, also früher war das so, ja,
wenn du da so einen Server hast, dann ist der halt an einem Ort und wenn du
mit dem reden möchtest und du rufst jetzt den Web-Server von irgendeiner Bude, die in den USA ist,
auf, dann steht der auch da und dann muss jedes deiner Datenpakete,
wenn du da auf einer Webseite rumklickst, erstmal über den Teich rüber und sagen, hallo,
ich würde gerne eine Verbindung aufbauen. und dann geht es wieder zurück über den Teich.
Ja, du darfst eine Verbindung aufbauen. Ja, jetzt möchte ich aber auch wirklich
eine Verbindung aufbauen.
Dann geht das so hin und her und auf einmal dauert es einfach Sekunden,
bis überhaupt da mal was anfängt zu laden und bis dann irgendwie alles da ist,
denkst du ja so, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Damit komme ich irgendwie nicht klar, weil du einfach gewohnt bist,
dass die Dinger einfach flutschen.
Und das Internet selber bietet eben das gar nicht.
Also das Internet hat Adressen, das Internet hat Namen für diese Adressen,
das Internet definiert, wie Webseiten aussehen und wie so ein Browser funktioniert und so weiter,
aber das Internet in seiner Architektur garantiert keine Low Latency,
Global Availability, das ist alles nicht Teil der Protokollwelt. Vielleicht wird es das.
Genau, das stimmt. Ich finde das eigentlich super. Und genau deswegen musst
du halt ganz, ganz kurze Nameserver-Einträge vergeben können,
am laufenden Band irgendwo da hinten eine Infrastruktur haben,
die einmal sich selber da irgendwie das Hütchenspiel um den Planeten macht,
wie die Sonne wandert mit deinem Service, dass dann gerade da wieder die Kapazität
in dem Datacenter ist, dann in dem, dann in dem.
Und dann vorne sagen, ja, pass auf, wenn du jetzt nach DNS fragst,
schicke ich dich dahin, jetzt pass an den Moment jetzt noch hier und jetzt müssen
wir hier wieder was skalieren, ähm.
Das ist crazy und das ist halt nicht Teil des Internets als solchen,
sondern das sind einfach Dienstleistungen, die eben jetzt von einigen wenigen
Unternehmen, die weit in die Zukunft geblickt haben oder zumindest ein gutes Gefühl dafür hatten,
entwickelt wurden und von denen sich jetzt alle sehr schnell abhängig gemacht haben.
Und jetzt hast du eben auch da diesen Netzwerkeffekt, weil es ja auch irgendwo
Quatsch wäre, so eine Infrastruktur, wenn sie erstmal da ist,
tausendfach zu haben, eben weil es gar nicht möglich ist.
Das würde sich nicht wieder finanzieren, du würdest das Personal nicht finden etc.
Und du würdest viel Technologie duplizieren, die so gar nicht in fünf- und zehnfacher
Ausführung gebraucht werden würde.
Und von daher hängen wir einfach an der Stelle in der Servicequalität des Netzes
und auch in seiner Resilienz von diesen privaten Betreibern extrem ab,
was natürlich dann wieder neue Flaschenhälse schafft,
beziehungsweise eben auch so Single Point of Failures, wie zum Beispiel ein
kleiner Programmierfehler und schon kippt da so eine ganze Kaskade um.
Ja, wir sind mit den meisten Programmierfehlern.
Ja gut, aber dass es dann eben auch gleich so eine globale Auswirkung hat und
alles bis du deine Matratze irgendwie runterreißt, das ist ja schon absurd.
Ich meine, früher haben wir so ein bisschen darüber gekichert.
Das mit der Matratze hat mich überrascht.
Ja, aber früher war es immer so, oh Gott, was ist denn, wenn unser Kühlschrank mit dem Internet redet?
Das war ja lange Zeit so ein Lacher.
Da lacht heute keiner mehr.
Der Glückschrank macht einen Gigabyte und ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn der Pit umkippt irgendwie, dann fängt der an, irgendwie deinen Joghurt aufzuessen.
Die,
Also, man könnte dem entgegenhalten, dass Internet, wie es jetzt,
also die Technologien, auf denen das Internet basiert,
als die entwickelt wurden, hat ja auch keiner die Vision,
dass es irgendwie riesengroße internationale Services mit Nutzerinnenzahlen
im dreistelligen Millionen- bis Milliarden-Bereich.
Geben würde. Hat ja keiner gesagt, lass das mal machen.
Genau, dafür designen wir das jetzt mal.
Dafür wurden, ich glaube, da habe ich wahrscheinlich vor 15,
16, 20 Jahren bei Netzpolitik.org auch geschrieben, das Video-Streaming,
dafür ist Internet nicht gedacht.
Also Broadcasting. Es ist wirklich keine gute Idee, also wenn du ein Fußballspiel
verbreiten möchtest, also als Idee.
Sagst du, pass auf, lass mal überlegen. Wir wollen, alle wollen gleichzeitig was gucken.
Was machen wir? Dann sagst du, naja, nehmen wir irgendwie ein geeignetes Frequenzband,
womit man weit genug kommt, und dann machen wir das mit Funk.
Und dann stellst du irgendwann fest, okay, kannst du machen,
aber hast du nicht genug Bandbreite in der Frequenz, mit der du irgendwie in
jeden Keller kommst, dann sagst du, na gut, dann lass uns das doch an Satelliten,
senden, und der hat wenigstens nichts im Weg, und dann können wir mit einem
Satelliten die Hälfte der Erde beballern.
Was Leute ja auch gemacht haben für Fernsehen, gibt es glaube ich immer noch.
Astra, Eulsat und was gibt es noch?
Naja, alles Mögliche. Jede Region hat ihre stationären Fernsehsatelliten und nicht zu wenig.
Genau, das ist eine Technologie, die dafür geeignet ist, vielen Leuten gleichzeitig etwas zu senden.
Fernsehen über Internet war wirklich jetzt nicht klug.
Würde man meinen.
Dann haben sie immer gesagt, okay, Multicast und irgendwelche,
haben sie ein bisschen was an den Protokollen gezaubert, aber am Ende muss,
wenn 100 Leute oder 100.000 Leute Tagesschau streamen, muss 100.000 Mal die
Tagesschau irgendwo rausgesendet werden.
Und diese Orte, weil kein einzelner Server das kann, musst du davon halt mehrere
haben, musst du die skalieren und also ja, also ich weiß nicht genau,
also ich finde es halt, ich finde es interessant, einerseits darauf zu denken
und sagen, ja, das Internet hätte,
das unterstützt das nicht, das war da nie für gedacht, jetzt haben wir aber
nun mal uns entschieden, dass wir alle bei Amazon kaufen und,
zum Beispiel auch eben alle mit Signal kommunizieren wollen,
man würde jetzt auch nicht akzeptieren, dass du auf, dass man auf Signal Berlin
ist und sich auf einen anderen Server einloggen muss, wenn man auf,
wenn man, was weiß ich, in Hamburg ist, weil man dann in Signal Hamburg ist oder so, ne?
Also müssen die, die unterhalten, eine weltweit skalierende Infrastruktur.
Und wenn die dann mal einen Fehler hat, dann ist es halt kaputt.
Und damit müssen wir rechnen. Und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht,
dass sich das mittelfristig ändern wird.
Also vielleicht sogar auch langfristig nicht ändern wird.
Also vielleicht so in ein paar hundert Jahren kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass das alles auf einer ganz anderen technologischen Basis angekommen ist.
Aber diese Sachen halten sehr lange.
Bis was billigeres kommt.
Meistens was ich meine ist in dem
Moment wo man erkennt dass solche Dinge quasi eine Grundanforderung sind die
man immer haben will dann kann man sich ja schon denken dass das Internet quasi
auf Basis seiner Standards so weiterentwickelt wird dass das quasi eine Eigenschaft
des Netzes ist dass du dafür gar keinen,
Betreiber brauchst aber davon sind wir noch weit entfernt.
Allein schon deshalb, weil die Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich diese Dienste und
auch die Nachfrage nach diesen Diensten entwickelt, derzeit alles abhängt,
was in irgendeiner Form mit einem Standard hinterherkommen könnte.
Also ein Standard muss ja auch erstmal schauen, okay, hat sich was etabliert?
Lässt sich das allgemein beschreiben?
Kann man sich da auf irgendwas einigen?
Jetzt machen wir das mal, dann ist das beschlossen, dann muss das umgesetzt werden und so weiter.
Also da vergehen Jahre und Jahrzehnte und in derselben Zeit bist du wahrscheinlich
in einem anderen Bereich schon wieder ganz woanders.
Und von daher ist das einfach eine Realität, die wir akzeptieren müssen.
Ist vielleicht manchmal nicht schön, aber ist halt einfach so.
Ja, das muss man glaube ich schon noch ein bisschen in die Details schauen,
weil bei Signal, also bei den Matratzen, okay.
Für irgendwelche Videostreaming-Sachen vielleicht auch, aber Signal ist natürlich
auch noch mal einen besonders ähm,
Besonders sensibles System, ja, weil es ja ein Ende-zu-Ende-verschlüsselter
privater Messenger ist.
Und wenn die Signal-Infrastruktur bei Amazon steht und letztendlich von Amazon
betrieben wird, da können ein paar Signal-Entwickler irgendwie ein bisschen
Code schreiben für ihre Server, dürfen den auf Amazon deployen.
Aber am Ende entscheidet Amazon, ob die IP-Adressen, die sich dahin verbinden,
geloggt werden oder nicht.
Klammer auf, ist an jeder anderen Stelle, wo du einen Server hinstellst,
auch so, dass jemand das loggen kann oder nicht.
Aber am Ende läuft Signal auf Amazon-Servern.
Wenn da irgendeiner hingeht und sagt, wo ist hier bitte übrigens gerade meine
Signal-Nachricht langgegangen, dann gehört dieser Rechner Amazon und nicht der Signal-Foundation.
Klar sagt sie aber natürlich, Deswegen wird Signal ja auch genau so gebaut,
dass die Messages Ende-zu-Ende verschlüsselt sind, dass man quasi auch so weit
wie möglich der Infrastruktur, auf der man läuft,
nicht vertraut und eben Ende-zu-Ende Verschlüsselung implementiert,
sodass weder Signal noch Amazon die Sachen sehen kann.
Aber das, was Signal sehen kann, all das, was Signal sehen kann, kann auch Amazon sehen.
Also baut Signal die Sachen so, dass sie nichts sehen können. Ja.
Das muss man dann Signal und wahrscheinlich jedem anderen Messenger,
der Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, in ähnlicher Form zugutehalten,
weil auch WhatsApp wird nicht selber betreiben.
Und dann kommt aber natürlich ein Argument, was wir an dieser Stelle schon gelten
lassen müssen oder auch erwähnen müssen.
Naja, gibt genug Leute, die sagen, deswegen macht man auch keine zentralisierten
Systeme, weil man genau dann nämlich auf so einer AWS-Kürze landet.
Und zumindest kann man ja, denke ich sagen,
Mastodon als Beispiel für eine dezentrale Alternative zu einem zentralen Social
Network System, wie es Twitter oder Facebook oder so wären,
funktioniert und skaliert ja auch.
Und wenn jetzt dann irgendwas bei Amazon platt ist, dann merkt es halt keiner,
weil kaum jemand seine, oder vielleicht einige, aber die meisten eben nicht,
ihre Mastodon-Instanzen bei AWS hosten.
Ja, vielleicht auch, das wäre auch nochmal interessant, das wäre eigentlich
lustig, habe ich jetzt nicht darauf geachtet, wie viele Mastodon-Instanzen platt waren.
Ja, aber das Wahrscheinlich sind es wenige, weil sich das für so dauerhaft im
Betrieb befindliche Server eigentlich nicht wirklich lohnt.
Das wird sich auch nicht so ziemen sein, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber Meredith schließt natürlich damit auch, dass sie sagt, ja,
sollte man mal sehen, wie, was das hier bedeutet, wenn das da halt alles von
einigen wenigen privaten Infrastrukturanbietern abhängt.
Und nicht irgendwie von Deutsche Telekom oder sonst wem.
Wir haben das natürlich auch, diese Zusammenhänge hier ja auch schon öfter mal
behandelt, wenn es um so Fragen wie Netzneutralität geht und sich eben die Frage
stellt, naja, woran machen wir die jetzt eigentlich noch fest, für wen?
Was ist jetzt hier? Ist Netzneutralität eine IP-Routing-Frage?
Ist das eine...
Auf welcher Ebene muss diese Neutralität denn eigentlich sein?
Scheiße, Amazon.
Schon geil, wenn der Chat flutscht.
Ja, schon ganz cool, wenn man irgendwie, wenn man so ein Häkchen kriegt,
hat die Nachricht gelesen, da war es halt, ja.
Also riesiges, also es gibt ein Risiko durch Zentralisierung und damit wird
natürlich auch wirklich dieses Internet ad absurdum geführt,
was ja mal gebaut wurde, um eben,
dezentral Paket-Routing, Paket-Routing statt Circuit-Switched-Routing,
das war schon alles, um resiliente Infrastrukturen zu bauen für Amazon.
Klar, die Kontrolle über diese Infrastrukturen ist eben auch die Kontrolle über
große Teile der funktionierenden digitalen Welt.
Und auch irgendwie so ein unabhängiger Dienst wie Signal hängt davon ab und
da muss man, sollte man Bewusstsein für entwickeln und potenziell natürlich
das auch mal vielleicht rein regulieren.
Wenn wir nämlich mal ein Beispiel nehmen, was bedeutet das,
wenn ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen die große Infrastruktur betreibt?
Es gibt ja den internationalen Strafgerichtshof.
Hattest du mit dem schon mal zu tun, Tim?
Bisher eher weniger.
Eines der wenigen Gerichte.
Mit dem man eigentlich nichts zu tun haben will.
Wo wir auch, mit dem wir hoffentlich niemals in Frage kommen.
Berlin Amtsgericht, Landgericht, alles schon hinter mir.
Aber Internationaler Strafgerichtshof.
Leute, mit denen ich mich bisher nicht angelegt habe.
Allerdings hat sich 2024 der Chefankläger, Wie heißt er mit Vornamen? Khan.
Karim Khan hat Haftbefehl gegen Israels Premier Benjamin Netanyahu erlassen,
gegen seinen Verteidigungsminister und gegen zwei Hamas-Führer.
Drei. Drei sogar. So, der hat auf jeden Fall ein paar Haftbefehle erlassen.
Und es ist natürlich klar, dass das nur, das ist ja völlig klar,
das werden ja auch alle wissen, das kann sich ja dabei nur um einen fürchterlichen
Akt, der des Antisemitismus gehandelt haben.
Klar.
Sagt er auch, Netanyahu sagte dann, das ist einer der großen Antisemiten der Moderne.
Der Richter.
Bitte?
Der Chefankläger ist das. Und dann der An.
Also natürlich, so eine fürchterliche Form von Antisemitismus ist nicht zu dulden.
Deswegen hat dann auch US-Präsident Donald Trump gesagt, alles klar,
gegen den werden die USA jetzt Sanktionen erheben.
Ja, denn dieses Gericht hat ja mit der Beantragung eines Haftverfehls gegen
Netanyahu seine Macht missbraucht.
Ja, so.
Und dann hatte der gute Karim Khan seit Anfang des Jahres keinen Zugriff mehr
auf seine dienstlichen E-Mails, weil die nämlich bei Microsoft lagen.
Und wenn die USA sagen, Microsoft, das ist hier ein sanktioniertes Individuum,
dann sagt Microsoft, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Und dann kriegt er halt kein E-Mail mehr.
Wenn man jetzt mal so über Macht von zentraler Infrastruktur sprechen möchte,
so einfach mal, wenn man das Thema jetzt mal so hat.
Und wenn der bei AWS was hosten möchte, kriegt er das auch nicht.
Der ist quasi jetzt digital geächtet.
Der ist on offline.
Zwangsoffline.
Und das führt dazu, dass der internationale Strafgerichtshof sagt,
naja, lass mal überlegen, wir sind also jetzt hier der internationale Strafgerichtshof, okay, so.
Und die USA machen bei uns ja eh nicht mit.
Habe ich richtig im Kopf, ne? Internationalen Strafgerichtshof erkennen die Amerikaner nicht an.
Und dann sagen die, hm, jetzt gibt es also dieses Land, eines von wenigen,
die uns irgendwie nicht anerkennen und die außerdem damit unzufrieden sind,
wie wir unsere Aufgabe als Internationalen Strafgerichtshof wahrnehmen und Haftbefehl gegen jemanden,
wie könnte man das sagen, gegen jemanden erlassen, gegen den ein begründeter
Anfangsverdacht besteht.
Dass der vielleicht ein paar Leute zu viel umgebracht hat.
Ja, so begründen. Und man, müssen wir mal kurz nochmal nachzählen.
Nur mal Kontrollen. Ist ja nur der Anklicker, ist ja noch keine Verurteilung.
Und dann haben wir auf einmal kein E-Mail mehr.
Geil. Da hätten sie mal gleich die E-Mail genommen.
Haben sie ja zu Glück. Zum Glück haben sie jetzt gesagt, okay,
dann gehen wir jetzt von Microsoft Office weg und zwar zu OpenDesk,
was von dem Zentrum für digitale Souveränität in seiner Entwicklung unterstützt und koordiniert wird.
Das ist jetzt ein Fall von...
Ja, digitale Souveränität. Also ich muss echt sagen, Alter, wenn du auf einmal
kein E-Mail, wenn du es auf einmal, du hast, Köln-Kalk-Verbot ist nichts gegen
Microsoft-Cloud-Verbot.
Ja, also vor allem, ich meine internationaler Strafgerichtshof,
ich glaube diese internationale Justiz,
diese international hoch aufgehängten Organisationen wenden sich bis vor kurzem
auch noch so ein bisschen auf Papststatus.
Nobody fucks with the Pope und irgendwie so internationaler Strafgerichtshof.
Ich glaube, die dachten auch so, also uns kann ja irgendwie keiner was, warum auch.
Wir sind ja hier die obersten Richter und lassen es mal alle schön in Ruhe.
Das funktioniert aber jetzt nicht mehr so richtig.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie gut du hier noch richtest ohne E-Mail. Das ist schon echt.
Nee, aber dann wird es halt konkret. Zumal wir jetzt eben durch diese Verflechtung,
durch diese Verflechtung durch das Internet,
die Verflechtung durch solche Dienste und Anwendungen auch eine Verflechtung
der Rechtssysteme bekommen. Ja.
Und das ist natürlich für den juristischen Bereich und speziell auch für Europa
eine absolute Herausforderung, weil man muss jetzt dieses Problem lösen und
das haben wir ja schon auch in anderer Form hier oft behandelt.
Wo darf was gesperrt werden? Wer darf eigentlich wem was untersagen?
Welches Recht gilt denn jetzt eigentlich, wenn ich hier irgendwie international
im Internet unterwegs bin?
Ist es jetzt irgendwie die amerikanische oder die deutsche Vorstellung von Copyright?
Ist es die amerikanische oder die russische Vorstellung von wer ist jetzt hier Terrorist etc. pp.
Und das wird natürlich nicht weniger und eben auch was solche Souveränitätsaspekte
betrifft, stellt sich jetzt diese Frage nochmal ganz neu.
Weil das kann halt nicht sein, weil im Prinzip könnte ja Donald Trump auch dem
gesamten Bundestag seine E-Mail entziehen.
Wenn der Bundestag seine E-Mail bei Microsoft hat, ja.
Naja, also ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau im Einzelnen, wo welcher Dienst wie
gehostet ist und da mag es auch eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit geben.
Aber wenn Deutschland sozusagen Office entzogen wird, kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass also noch weniger funktioniert als außer den Matratzen.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Da funktionieren die Matratzen auch offline nicht mehr, weil die Leute einfach
keinen Schlaf mehr kriegen.
Also die dbtg.de ist der Mail 1-4.dbtg dbtg.de.
Also ich glaube, der Bundestag wird schon seine eigene Mail-Server haben,
aber wir wissen alle, wo es irgendwie ist.
Ja, wenn die bei Amazon gekostet sind, hast du trotzdem keine Mail.
Ja, aber wenn du den Leuten Office wegnimmst, ich glaube, wenn du Office wegnimmst,
dann bin ich irgendwie der Einzige, der noch arbeiten kann.
Ja, ich würde sagen, die werden nicht mehr arbeiten können, aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass die Wirtschaft trotzdem einen starken Sprung in ihrer Produktivität
macht, weil die Leute dann plötzlich irgendwie mal was erledigen können, ja, statt zu arbeiten.
Aber das sind andere Perspektiven.
Es ist auf jeden Fall natürlich der Machtmissbrauch, der hier durch diese Sanktionierung stattfindet.
Ist ja vor allem faszinierend, weil er so kleinteilig ist.
Weil so der da, der da, der ist jetzt auf der Liste und jetzt hat er kein E-Mail mehr.
So das ist Macht, ja. Alles andere ist irgendwie Kinkerlitzchen.
Aber wenn du sagst, der Typ da, der ist auf der Liste und Microsoft sagt,
okay, dann kriegt der jetzt halt keine Mails mehr. Tut mir leid.
Ich meine, das ist halt so, als wäre Osama Bin Laden oder so jemand gewesen.
Wo man dann, da wäre man wahrscheinlich auch empört gewesen,
wenn Microsoft gesagt hätte, dem stellen wir eine E-Mail zu.
Jetzt ist es andersrum.
Ja, es ist schon, und das ist, also da gibt es halt wirklich,
und ich glaube, also das sollte man wirklich, jetzt kommt ein wichtiger Punkt,
ja, das ist gerade ein Machtkampf, der da stattfindet.
Und dieser Machtkampf ist genau das, wenn Europa sagt,
ja wir betreiben diesen ganzen Scheiß nicht und ja uns ist auch klar,
dass wir uns hier in irgendwelchen ökonomischen Abhängigkeiten,
Zentralisierung, aber vor allem in eine nicht auflösbare Abhängigkeit begeben.
Und solange wir hier noch ein halbwegs brauchbarer Markt sind,
formulieren wir eben Digital Service Act, DSGVO, Digital Markets Act, um all diese Dinger,
um irgendwie unsere Macht als dieser große Markt, mit dem diese Unternehmen
viel Geld verdienen, zu nutzen, um Standards zu setzen, die das irgendwie noch
halbwegs im Griff halten.
Das heißt, Europa wehrt sich mit Regulierung.
Das Imperium Europas wird versucht, durch Regeln und Bürokratie und Regulierungen
sich zu festigen in dieser Welt.
Und das Imperium USA schafft halt einfach die Infrastruktur, auf der alles läuft.
Und Russland, China, Indien bauen ihren eigenen Scheiß und warten noch ein bisschen,
bis wir irgendwann untergegangen sind.
Aber das ist schon wirklich ein Problem, was da stattfindet.
Weißt du, wenn jetzt die Russen eine Alternative zur AWS machen würden,
würde ich auch wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt nutzen wollen.
Nee, auch die chinesischen Angebote sind mir ehrlich gesagt dann ziemlich Wumpe.
Ja, die haben auch ein bisschen große Latenz dann hier.
Also es muss auf jeden Fall, es ist unrealistisch davon auszugehen,
dass wir in Europa alles irgendwie komplett repliziert und selbst betrieben bekommen,
aber wichtig ist, dass man sich mal auf den Weg begibt und das bedeutet,
man muss einfach eine ganz andere Einstellung auch zur Digitalisierung entwickeln,
insbesondere in Deutschland,
weil Deutschland ist einfach meiner Meinung nach das Hauptproblem.
Das ist hier einfach mal die Bremsernation Nummer 1.
Und nicht, dass es nicht noch ein paar rückständigere Länder gibt,
aber jetzt im Verhältnis zu der
Größe und Bedeutung von Deutschland ist es einfach nur wirklich schlimm.
Ich war jetzt irgendwie eine Woche in Albanien, da gibt es auch überall Mobilfunk und so.
Das war jetzt noch nicht ganz so durchdigitalisiert.
Aber damit muss man sich dann halt irgendwie messen. Egal, ich will jetzt nicht
mein altes Klagelied deswegen wieder anheben.
Es braucht eine klare Orientierung hin zu digitaler Souveränität.
Man muss all diese Abhängigkeiten jetzt auf den Prüfstand stellen.
Hätte man schon längst tun sollen, aber jetzt wird es langsam mal wirklich dringend.
Und man muss sich angewöhnen, mehr Resilienztests aufzuhören. auch durchzuführen.
Also so ein Alarm Tag, so ein Warntag ist ja schön und gut. Das hat es auch gebraucht.
Die kommen übrigens auch garantiert über irgendeinen AWS-Server.
Kannst du ja nicht erklären. Oder zumindest kommen die ja dann über, das sowieso, die,
Apple-Notification-Dinger kommen dann halt irgendwie über eine Apple-Cloud und
Apple legt den Krempel im Zweifelsfall würde ich vermuten bei Amazon hin.
Oder meinst du, die legen den bei Google oder Microsoft hin?
Also ich hätte eine Idee wählen, wo die das am ehesten hinlegen.
Die haben natürlich am Ende auch mit allen dreien ganz gute Konkurrenzverhältnisse, ne?
Apple jetzt konkret, die benutzen alles. Also die benutzen eigene Datacenters,
aber auch die haben halt nicht für alles alles.
Also alle hängen auch irgendwie an allen dran.
Aber Europa muss sich einfach mehr in dieser Richtung überlegen und es braucht einfach auch mal Tests.
Man muss sich auch selber mal den Teppich mal unterm Boden wegziehen.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die eigene Backup-Strategie. Überprüfen.
Was ist denn jetzt, wenn mein Telefon weg ist? Komme ich dann noch an alles ran?
Das ist so ein schöner Test. Schließt mal euer Smartphone, schaltet das mal
aus und legt es in den Kühlschrank und,
schaltet alle eure Computer und was ihr sonst noch an Systemen habt,
aus und dann wieder an. Aber das Telefon nicht.
Und dann guckt mal, was noch geht. Habe ich alle Passwörter?
Was ist, wenn irgendein Teil wegfällt? Und so muss man das halt mit der ganzen Infrastruktur machen.
Apple größtenteils bei Amazon.
Alle iCloud-Services und Backups und iMessage sind bei Amazon,
außerdem Storage von iCloud dann eher bei Google,
bei GCP und Microsoft eher nicht.
Also Amazon und Google liegen die Apple-Sachen.
Dieses Thema.
Ja, beim Thema der Chat-Kontrolle sieht es jetzt danach aus, dass nachdem jetzt,
wir haben das ja zuletzt hier mit Thomas und Khaleesi besprochen,
dass Dänemark dann gesagt hat, okay, wir machen die verpflichtende Chat-Kontrolle,
bringt Dänemark nicht in diese Sitzung auf die Agenda, um die Abstimmung zu,
machen, weil eben Deutschland sich stark dagegen positioniert hat,
damit keine Mehrheit klar war und eine Abstimmung, die abgelehnt wird, macht man lieber nicht.
Deswegen haben sie jetzt aus ihrem Kompromissvorschlag das verpflichtende Scanning
wieder rausgenommen und damit bleibt eben jetzt das zunächst einmal wieder freiwillig.
Das heißt also, es wäre jetzt, wenn das dabei bliebe, zunächst einmal ein wieder sehr wichtiger,
entscheidender Etappensieg in die Richtung, dass die Idee einer verpflichtenden
Chatkontrolle zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt mal wieder gerade ganz kurz vom Tisch ist,
bis der Nächste kommt, sich wieder anders überlegt.
Aber es wäre gerade eine gute Entwicklung in die richtige Richtung.
Das ist jetzt so vor einigen Stunden der Stand,
weil Calicia gerade erst mit Thomas bei uns war und hat das jetzt etwas gewirkt
offenbar in dieser Richtung.
Weil sie bei uns waren, hat es gewirkt.
Genau. Also das verpflichtete Scannen lassen sie fallen und sie werden jetzt
freiwilliges Scannen für Risikominimierung.
Und das geht natürlich in den Kontext, weil es diese sogenannte E-Privacy Derogation,
also die Abweichung von der tatsächlichen E-Privacy verordnet und die nämlich
genauso solche Scannen verbietet.
Das ist ja das Problem, was sie damals zunächst gelöst haben,
indem sie gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt eine Ausnahme davon.
Diese Ausnahme läuft aber immer aus.
Und jetzt könnte man eben sehen, ob sie mit dem Ding eine Mehrheit im Rat bekommen.
Die polnische Ratspräsidentschaft hat mit diesem halbwegs okayen Vorschlag,
der keine akute Verschlechterung gegenüber jetzt hat.
Herbeiführen oder keine große spürbare Verschlechterung gegenüber dem jetzt
geltenden Status Quo mit dieser Ausnahme herbeiführen würde.
Aber jetzt werden sie das halt mal diskutieren. Aber Dänemark hat aus dieser
Situation zumindest erstmal gelernt und die Taktik in dieser Auseinandersetzung jetzt geändert.
Alright.
Dann gab es eine wunderschöne Meldung. Solche Meldung, da freut sich das Herz
des Überwachungsstaates.
Anfang Oktober ist in Frankfurt eine 16-Jährige aus einer psychiatrischen Einrichtung verschwunden.
Und es ist davon ausgegangen, dass sie in einer psychiatrischen Ausnahmesituation war.
Es ist so, wenn man in einer psychiatrischen Einrichtung ist,
dann meistens, wenn man in einer Ausnahmesituation ist.
Daraufhin hat dann das Polizeipräsidium eine Eilanordnung vorgenommen.
Diese wurde durch eine Richterin bestätigt und dann durfte das Foto,
ein Foto dieser Dame in eine Bilddatenbank eingespeist werden von Menschen, nach denen mit,
nach denen automatisch in den Überwachungskameras, in diesem Fall der Stadt
Frankfurt am Main, gesucht wird.
Sie sind davon ausgegangen, dass sie sich im Bahnhofsviertel aufhalten würde
und dort kommt eben auch ein KI-gestütztes Videosystem zum Einsatz und es hat
dann nicht lange gedauert,
bis dieses System gesagt hat, das könnte dieses Gesicht sein,
nach dem ich hier suchen soll.
Dann hat einer der Videoüberwachungsmitarbeiter gesagt, das könnte die wohl tatsächlich sein.
Und dann hat er einer Streife Bescheid gesagt und dann haben sie die Frau wohlbehalten
am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof gefunden und zurück in die Psychiatrie gebracht.
Ich würde sagen vom Regen in die Traufe, weil ich glaube Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof oder Psychiatrie,
beides Orte, wo ich schwer zwischen wählen könnte, würde ich immer noch fragen,
ob es nicht noch eine dritte Option gibt, weil Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof ist
wirklich kein schöner Ort.
Aber das wird natürlich jetzt sehr gefeiert. Der Innenminister sagt,
genau für solche Fälle ist der Einsatz von KI in Videoschutzanlagen dringend
erforderlich, um Menschen in Gefahr schnell helfen zu können.
Ja, das war jetzt hier, glaube ich, was hier fehlt ist, dass die Frau jetzt
irgendwie am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof in Gefahr war ja, weil ich glaube,
wer am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof ist grundsätzlich in Gefahr,
aber das trifft dann eben auf alle zu, die da sind, ja, ausnahmslos da gibt
es, also, das ist einfach ein gefährlicher Ort, aber ähm.
Jetzt ausgerechnet, wenn ich jetzt mal ausgerechnet eine 16-Jährige,
die aus der Psychiatrie ausbricht, dass das jetzt hier irgendwie das Poster-Child
von der Videoüberwachung am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof wird.
Auch ohne Videoüberwachung würden mir einige Verbesserungen einfallen,
die man am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof vornehmen könnte.
Der Kontext ist, dass das hessische Polizeigesetz vor einiger Zeit geändert wurde.
Das haben wir hier sicherlich auch behandelt. Die Änderung trat im Februar dann in Kraft.
Und diese Änderung erlaubt nämlich KI zur Suche in den Videoüberwachungsanlagen
zur Suche von vermissten Personen einzusetzen.
Hier steht immer Videoschutzanlagen, aber die schützen ja überhaupt gar keine
Videos. Insofern ist das Quatsch.
Datenschutz schützt ja auch keine Daten.
Nee.
Das wird natürlich jetzt gefeiert. Und jetzt hast du, das sind dann so,
dann nennst du deine KI-Überwachung Videoschutzanlage und rettest ein kleines Mädchen,
wobei es jetzt keine Schilderung gab, dass sie irgendwie in Gefahr wäre oder
gewesen wäre oder größere oder geringere Gefahr.
Dadurch, dass sie am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof war, als jetzt jeder andere, der das,
Ich meine, sicherlich wird es der, ich meine, du bist nicht in der psychiatrischen
Einrichtung, wenn du dann nicht im Zweifelsfall auch darauf angewiesen bist,
dass dir da geholfen wird oder so.
Aber es ist schon eine, es passt irgendwie schon, dass es dann am Ende doch
ein kleines Mädchen ist, was wir damit gerettet haben.
Ja, naja, also ich will ja noch nicht mal ausschließen, dass das jetzt hier
in dem Sinne für alle Beteiligten dann auch einen positiven Aspekt hatte.
Also ohne Frage, natürlich.
Wobei ich sag mal ohne jetzt irgendeine Hypothese zu machen aber wer aus der
Psychiatrie rausgeht und am Bahnhof dann ist,
da würde ich vermuten dass er ziemlich
zielstrebig hingegangen ist und wahrscheinlich auch dahin wollte ja,
Also sie ist jetzt nicht entführt in Afghanistan gefunden worden oder so.
Also das mit der Rettung würde ich dann auch nochmal die Person fragen,
ob sie sagt, ja das ist großartig, dass ich hier aus der Gefahr des Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhofs entfernt wurde.
Und das war genau nochmal gut, dass es die KI-basierten Videoüberwachungssysteme
gibt, dass ich jetzt wieder in der Psychiatrie bin.
Herzlichen Dank. Bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob die jetzt in dieser Situation,
auch gesagt hat, ein Hoch auf die KI-Überwachung.
Danke, dass der Computer mich gerettet hat.
Ja, also ich meine, die nächste Eskalationsstufe ist natürlich dann so,
das hat das jetzt so schön funktioniert, jetzt müssen wir das auch noch mit,
Geflohenen aus dem Gefängnis machen.
Wobei die ja meistens eigentlich auch schnell wieder so wieder eingefangen werden,
auch ohne KI, zumindest bisher immer so.
Und dann wird man natürlich auch irgendwann anfangen, Leute zu suchen,
die vielleicht von irgendjemandem vermisst werden, aber die vielleicht gar kein
Interesse daran haben, gefunden zu werden.
Oder den Haftbefehl gegen Benjamin Netanyahu aus flammendem Antisemitismus oder sowas.
Ja, also das muss man auf jeden Fall im Auge behalten. Wenn hier von KI die
Rede ist, dann reden wir hier wirklich jetzt eher von so der,
einfachen KI, also was man eigentlich eher mit Machine Learning beschreibt,
was halt irgendwie ganz gute Ergebnisse erzielt bei,
Gesichtserkennung und Personenerkennung. Das funktioniert leider halt sehr gut jetzt.
Ja, Daniela Klette kann da ein Lied von singen. Die ist ja auch in ihre Einrichtung zurückgekommen.
Und die wollte ja auch nicht gefunden werden.
Ja, psychische Ausnahmesituation, wir haben ja mal geholfen.
Komm, wir machen noch ein bisschen Cyber.
Ja, Cybercrime. Cybercrime ist jetzt auch vorbei. Das ist gut, das Cybercrime.
Nee, erstmal haben wir noch einen anderen Cyber.
Ach, Gott. Ach so.
Wer in den letzten Wochen mal versucht hat, von Berlin zu fliegen,
musste feststellen, dass über drei Wochen oder was gab es an diesem Flughafen.
Schwierigkeiten. Die haben sich da berappelt, aber ich glaube,
ich hatte das auch hier erzählt, dass da die Leute beim Check-in das mit dem Auge machen.
Die kommen mit dem Auge den QR-Code dann anschauen. Habe ich das nicht erzählt?
Was meinst du jetzt bei dem Runway oder?
Nee, ich gehe dann bis zum, also willst du ein Flugzeug, ne?
Üblicherweise kaufst du dafür ein Ticket. Dann checkst du ein,
dann kriegst du QR-Code und diesen QR-Code hältst du auf einen Scanner.
Ja, Bordkarte heißt das.
Genau. Der, Bording Pass, aber ja, das,
System, was das gemacht hat, was dann BIP macht und dann sagt,
Herr Neumann, Sie sitzen am Notausgang, sind Sie psychisch in der Lage? Ja, bin ich, okay.
Das System ähm.
Das ging nicht. Und da waren dann Leute, da waren Menschen, so irgendwie ein
paar Tage nach dem dieser, es war natürlich ein Cyberangriff, ein Cyberangriff,
die Menschen haben dann, da waren Menschen, die haben dann immer so geguckt,
und ich habe mir nachher erklären lassen, die haben eigentlich nur auf die Sequence-Number
geguckt, die klein unter dem QR-Code steht.
Aber es wurde durch, die haben dann immer so per Telefon die Sequence-Numbers
durchgegeben und hinten saß jemand, hat Strichliste, das gemacht.
Also es ging ohne dieses System und ungefähr drei Wochen hat es noch gedauert,
bis du bis die Anzeigetafeln, die über dem Gate sind, dass dort steht welcher
Flug und dass der jetzt boardet.
Also es stand immer nur boardet gleich, aber nicht boarding jetzt.
Das funktionierte drei Wochen lang nicht.
Das war auf jeden Fall, woran hat es gelegen? Es war betroffen waren nicht nur
der Flughafen BER, sondern auch Brüssel,
Dublin und London Heathrow, weil die alle einen Dienstleister nutzen.
Und zwar ist das der Dienstleister Collins Aerospace, der eine Reihe an Services
für die Luftfahrt anbietet.
Unter anderem eben diese Check-in-Systeme.
Gepäckabfertigung und Passagierabfertigung. Ähm.
Bin mir auch nicht, also ich weiß echt nicht, ob ich das hier erklärt habe,
aber es gibt ja, wenn du ein Flugticket hast, die haben immer so eine Buchungsnummer.
Kennst du noch? Die Amadeusnummer heißt die. Das sind glaube ich sechs Zeichen.
Mit dem, dieser alphanumerische Code.
Genau, ja. Und die werden immer, die sind immer nur eine Zeit lang gültig.
Und das, und ich habe mich so mit ein paar Luftfahrtleuten unterhalten,
die so keine Ahnung, so Sachen haben wie Airlines oder so, mit denen redet man ja mal.
Also IT und sowas da betreiben. Und ich habe immer gefragt, warum macht ihr
nicht eigentlich euer eigenes Check-in-System?
Warum macht ihr diesen Damadeus-Quatsch und so? Das ist ja auch alles irgendwie.
Jahrzehnte alter Murks und so.
Und der Hauptgrund ist, dass ich sage, das ist halt ein Standard,
den halt jeder Flughafen unterstützt.
Und wenn du jetzt beispielsweise als Airline, als Linus Air oder sowas hingehst
und sagst, pass auf, bei uns sehen die Boarding-Passes anders aus und wir machen
bei diesem ganzen Amadeus-Quatsch nicht mit,
dann musst du dir halt überlegen, wie du dich mit dem Flughafen BER darauf einigst,
dass deine Passagiere da reinkommen.
Also das sind halt große, zentralisierte Standards und dieser eine Passagierabfertigung
und sonst was wird eben von Collins Aerospace betrieben und die hatten einen Cyberangriff,
dann sind diese Systeme platt gewesen,
Check-in, Gepäckabfertigung an den Flughafen, die ich nannte,
Störungen, Verzögerungen waren die Folge.
Und gestern stolperte ich dann über eine kleine Meldung auf ccc.de.
Wir haben da ja dieses Disclosure-Programm.
Und bei lustigen Sachen, das macht ja hauptsächlich Kantorkel.
Bei lustigen Sachen schreibt er dann auch mal so einen kleinen Post dazu.
Und den möchte ich jetzt mal vorlesen.
Collins Aerospace mit Test, Test, Textnachrichten bis ins Cockpit senden.
Am 21.09., das ist ziemlich genau einen Monat vor diesem Cyberangriff,
konntest du dich mit den Nutzernamen-Test, Passwort-Test beim Erring-Op-Center-Message-Browser,
als US Navy Fleet Logistics Support Wing
einloggen und damit konntest du Textnachrichten bis ins Cockpit senden.
Das ist dann so ein A-Cars oder sowas heißt das dann.
Ich müsste mir jetzt nochmal angucken, was genau für Nachrichten die da gesendet haben.
Aber es gibt nicht so viele Nachrichten.
Die also quasi es ermöglichen,
Ja, Textnachrichten in Flugzeuge zu schicken. Und da konntest du halt bei denen
mit Test, Test rein. Genau, ACARS ist das, ja.
Also Collins Aerospace ist ja eigentlich traditionell überhaupt gar kein Softwareanbieter,
sondern es ist ja so ein bisschen wie mit Amazon, wie wir das vorhin schon hatten.
Die haben so ein bisschen auch aus der Not eine Tugend gemacht.
Die haben halt dann einfach angefangen, selber digitale Dienstleistungen noch
zusätzlich zu ihrem Hardwarekram, den sie bauen, bereitzustellen.
Und ja, so wie das funktioniert,
Sinnvoll ist, aus der Logik heraus, die wir vorhin erklärt haben,
AWS zu benutzen, ist es natürlich auch nachvollziehbar, dass Flughäfen an dieser
Stelle so eine Software benutzen.
Allein schon, weil sich ja da auch permanent was ändert.
Und wir wissen ja alle, wie leicht es jetzt...
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich da permanent was ändert, das ist ja ein 1970er Jahre Protokoll.
Die Anforderungen,
Regulationen und so weiter, also es ist ja nicht so, dass sich jetzt nichts dran ändern würde.
Achso, das ist als Service.
Ja, also an der Regulierung rund um Check-in von Passagieren ändert sich ja am laufenden Meter was.
PNR und wem was, wie, wo, wann. gemeldet werden muss und welche Metadaten übertragen werden.
Du willst damit sagen, dass es für eine Airline einfacher ist,
das einfach von jemand anders ausfassen zu lassen, der sich darum kümmert und nur darum kümmert.
Flughafen, in dem Fall sind es ja glaube ich die Flughäfen, die die Dienstleistungen
in Anspruch nehmen und das war ja nicht nur der BER, sondern hast ja auch schon
ein paar andere genannt, ich glaube auch irgendwie in Münster der Flughafen
und so weiter, also das ist schon sehr verbreitet.
Münster, so Städte wie Münster, ansonsten noch Brüssel und London,
aber Münster war auch auf jeden Fall ganz oben auf der Liste.
Verkehrsinfarkt kriegen, ja.
Anyway, also im Prinzip wieder die gleiche Geschichte, kritische Infrastruktur zentralisiert.
Es gibt gute Gründe dafür, das zu machen, aber wenn es dann kaputt ist,
weil der Cyber vorbeigekommen ist, dann fliegen die Flugzeuge nicht mehr.
Das ist im Prinzip wie mit den Matratzen.
Jedenfalls fand ich es lustig, dass dann bei dem gleichen Anbieter ausgerechnet
in diesem ACARS-System.
Das ist das Aircraft Communications Addressing and Reporting System,
also so ein Funk-Text-Nachrichtensystem.
Die Schwachstellenmeldung wurde von dem RTX Operation and Department of Defense
Cybercrime Center nicht bestätigt, aber der Account wurde dann deaktiviert.
Ja, also so der CCC, habt ihr euch den Spaß genommen, dass ihr kleine kostenlose
Nachrichten ans Cockpit schenken konntet. So sind wir.
Fand ich aber auf jeden Fall in dem Kontext ganz lustig. Aber Cybercrime ist ja sowieso verboten.
Genau. Ja, wir haben ja oft schon über die Cybercrime Convention gesprochen.
Thomas hat ja früh davon berichtet, als die Pläne erstmalig auftauchten und
hat da auch versucht zu vermitteln.
Hat alles nichts genutzt. Jetzt am 25. Oktober wurde in Hanoi in Vietnam diese
Cybercrime Convention symbolisch unterzeichnet.
Also das geht ja von der UN aus und das ist halt jetzt irgendwie so eine Initiative,
mit der sie irgendwie, ja,
Staaten sich dazu verpflichten wollen, einen bestimmten Umgang mit Cybercrime zu machen.
Den haben wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich analysiert und kritisiert.
Was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass 72 Staaten diese Unterschrift geleistet haben.
Das bedeutet rein technisch erstmal gar nichts, weil das nur so symbolisch ist.
Denn in irgendeiner Form in Kraft treten kann das ohnehin erst in den Ländern,
wenn diese Länder das auch offiziell ratifiziert haben.
Und insgesamt hat es eine staatenübergreifende Wirkung, wenn mindestens 40 Staaten das getan haben.
Da jetzt 72 unterschrieben haben, kann man davon ausgehen, dass diese 40 mittelfristig
dann irgendwann mal auch zusammenkommen.
Interessant ist, wer alles nicht unterschrieben hat, also die USA hat es nicht
unterschrieben, Deutschland hat es auch nicht unterschrieben,
aber die EU hat es unterschrieben.
Und außerdem noch in Europa die Slowakei, Österreich, Belgien,
Tschechien, Frankreich, Griechenland,
Irland, Luxemburg, Polen, Portugal, Slowenien,
Spanien und Schweden als auch UK und das laut einer Recherche von Netzpolitik.org im Übrigen.
Ja und Menschenrechtsgruppen und digitale freiheitsaktivistische Gruppen kritisieren das natürlich,
unter anderem Human Rights Watch, EFF, Privacy International,
Epicenter Works und Access Now haben das auch kritisiert und ein entsprechendes
Joint Statement rausgegeben, indem sie nochmal die Punkte zusammentragen,
warum sie der Meinung sind,
dass diese Cybercrime Convention überhaupt gar keine gute Idee ist und eben
eher Menschenrechte und Freiheitsrechte gefährdet.
Ja, okay.
Schön, super, toll. Haben sie jetzt auch das wieder gemacht,
wie Russland das geschafft hat.
Ja, ein Wunder. Aber man wundert sich fast schon nicht mehr.
Na gut. Kommen wir zu unserem Ausblick auf eine Fahrtschaltung. Der 39C3.
39C3, ich habe ja hier warte mal, wo ist das? Moment, ich kann ja sehen, wann er ist.
Der ist in 58 Tagen.
Wir hatten ja letzte Sendung auch schon darüber gesprochen, also Einreichungen,
die eingegangen sind für diese Veranstaltung.
758 Einreichungen.
Wir müssen noch kurz sagen, was ist denn 39C3?
Wer bis hierhin zugehört hat und hat nicht weiß, wird das jetzt sicher auch
noch deduzieren aus dem Kontext.
Deduzieren?
Ja.
Der 39. Chaos Communication Kongress. Du darfst jetzt fortfahren.
Achso, und jetzt wissen Sie, jetzt, achso.
Okay, also der 758 Einreichungen mit insgesamt 793 Einreichenden,
warum sind das mehr Einreichende als Einreichungen?
Weil natürlich pro Einreichung potenziell auch einige von der Funktion gebraucht
machen, dass man da zu zweit vortragen kann und das auch vorher sagt und nicht
erst nach der zweiten oder dritten Vorverkaufsrunde plötzlich.
Ich wollte ja noch, ich habe ja noch einen Co-Speaker, habe ich ganz vergessen zu erwähnen.
Sehr beliebte, also diese sehr gezeichnete zeitliche Korrelationen,
die echt überraschend sind.
Genau.
Die Einreichungen sind jetzt gerade im Begriff reviewt zu werden. Am 2.
November oder am Abend des 2. Novembers ist die Idee, die meisten zu- und absagen, zu versenden.
Ich sage das immer nur deshalb, weil das natürlich für uns sinnvoll ist,
finale Entscheidungen so schnell
wie möglich mitzuteilen, aber es manchmal tatsächlich Situationen gibt,
in denen man vielleicht doch nochmal einen Tag länger zwischen zwei Sachen diskutiert
oder auch feststellt, es gibt irgendwie eine Zusage, die nicht angenommen wird,
die zurückgezogen wurde oder sowas.
Also wenn ihr noch gar nichts gehört habt, dann heißt das, es ist noch nicht entschieden.
Aber die Idee ist, dass das potenziell in einem Rutsch dann über die Nacht vom 2. auf den 3.
November alles mitgeteilt wird. Das ist dieses Mal sehr anstrengend,
weil der Einreichungsschluss war ja erst vor kurzem, auch da haben wir ja letzte
Woche, der letzte Sendung mit Thomas und Kalisi drüber gesprochen,
die ja auch Einreichungen reviewen und da in der Programmauswahl mitwirken.
Und dann kann man bald Tickets kaufen. Das ist natürlich etwas sehr Spannendes.
Und zwar am 8. November um 11 Uhr und am 17.
November um 20 Uhr. Der 8. November 11 Uhr ist ein Samstag, das ist für die
Leute, die Samstag am Morgen früh aufstehen. und der 17.
November ist ein Montag, das sind 20, das ist für Leute, die montags spät aufstehen.
Und nein, das ist natürlich, damit wir in den anderen Zeitzonen,
wo unsere internationalen Freundinnen und Freunde herkommen,
ihnen auch eine Gelegenheit geben.
Ich weiß, oder ich kann ungefähr, oder ich möchte einmal vorhersagen, wie das laufen wird.
An dem 8. November.
Um 11 Uhr werden ganz viele F5 drücken, danach ein klitzekleines Capture-Rätsel
lösen und dann eine Wartenummer auf dem Screen stehen haben,
die irgendwo bei sehr, sehr, die sehr, sehr hoch ist.
Auf jeden Fall die Anzahl der verkaufbaren Tickets potenziell nah oder weit überschreitend ist.
Dann wird es absolute Panik geben woher man noch ein Ticket bekommt dann wird jedoch am 17.11.
Der Vorverkauf nicht mehr ganz so wild sein sodass nicht mehr Millisekunden
sondern wahrscheinlich,
Sekunden entscheiden über wer vorne in der Warteliste ist und noch etwas bekommt,
und dann ist bei dem 17.11.
Eine Sache noch wichtig wenn da eine hohe Zahl steht dann lasst das Browserfenster
auf und wartet, weil sehr viele Leute einfach Dropouten, wenn da eine hohe Zahl ist.
Also auch bei dem letzten Vorverkauf, wenn man weiß, da werden jetzt vielleicht
noch 5000 Tickets verkauft oder vier oder zweite.
Und man steht aber gleichzeitig dort und sieht, ah okay, ich habe Position 10.000,
gibt es eine sehr gute Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man trotzdem noch ein Ticket
bekommt, weil da eben sehr viele Leute sind, die ja auf ganz vielen Geräten
F5 drücken und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann werden noch einige Leute totale Panik kriegen und denken,
ah scheiße, ich habe kein Ticket bekommen und dann werden sie im Zweifelsfall
in der Woche irgendwie, was weiß ich, zwischen dem 14. und 21. Dezember.
Oder 14. bis 23. Dezember, natürlich, sorry,
dann doch noch irgendwo auf Ebay, auf Mastodon, über Freundinnen und Freunde
doch noch Tickets bekommen,
weil irgendwelche Leute wieder zu raffgierig waren und zu viele Tickets gekauft
haben oder krank werden oder ausfallen oder vergessen haben,
dass sie in Urlaub fahren oder doch nicht dahin wollen.
Man muss da, ich kann da nur ermutigen, wer dahin möchte,
darf sich nicht entmutigen lassen und muss halt vor allem die Nerven behalten,
weil ich so häufig, gerade kurz vor Weihnachten oder auch gerade kurz nach Weihnachten,
dann noch irgendwie Tickets da reingeballert werden und verschenkt werden.
Und ich den Eindruck habe, ja, es gibt natürlich eine große Nachfrage auf die
Tickets dieser Veranstaltung, das ist auch richtig und das hat zum Effekt,
dass diejenigen, die sich sehr um diese Tickets bemühen, da sind,
und dass viele Leute den Eindruck gewinnen, dass es absolut unmöglich ist,
ein solches Ticket zu bekommen und das glaube ich,
dieser Effekt ist aber halt auch daher verstärkt, dass eben dann alle auf fünf
Geräten Reload drücken und dass dann auf einer technischen Ebene eine sehr viel
höhere Nachfrage einprasselt,
als sie tatsächlich ist.
Insofern möchte ich euch ermutigen,
nicht aufzugeben und einfach dran zu bleiben und es zu versuchen. Genau.
Gib niemals auf und glaub an dich.
Oder ihr meldet euch für den Azubi-Tag an.
Müsst ihr einfach noch bis dahin jetzt, das wird natürlich auch eine Herausforderung,
habt ihr jetzt noch 58 Tage, bis ihr einen Ausbildungsplatz habt,
dann ist nämlich am Montag den 29.12, das ist ja der Tag 3 des Kongress, da ist der Azubi-Tag.
Da wird es eine Eröffnungsveranstaltung geben und danach könnt ihr dann eigenständig
über den Kongress laufen, Löt-Workshops für Interessierte, Ihr könnt,
wie gesagt, wenn ihr möchtet, einfach dann eigenständig da einen Tag verbringen.
Ihr könnt das irgendwie bei euren ausbildenden Betrieben irgendwie auch als
Fortbildung geltend machen.
Und dafür gibt es halt Tickets,
gibt auch ein reserviertes Kontingent für Non-Binary, weibliche,
Genderqueer, was auch immer irgendwie Personen, dass man quasi da sicherstellt,
dass die auch da repräsentiert sind.
Also müsst ihr euch, also quasi könnt ihr nochmal spezifisch auf dieses Kontingent,
seid ihr ein bisschen bevorteilt quasi.
Euch einen Tag länger Zeit lassen zu dürfen, bis ihr fragt, bis das Kontingent
weg ist und dann kann man eine Mail schreiben an 39c3-azubi at cccv.de sagt ihr,
wie viele Auszubildende aus welchen Ausbildungsberufen ihr seid und teilnehmen möchtet.
Name des Ausbildungsbetriebs und der Ausbildungsstätte und dann Nachweis der Ausbildung.
Also ihr müsst jetzt wirklich, das könnte zum Beispiel Bescheinigung der Berufsschule
sein oder der Ausbildungsstätte müsste jetzt nochmal gucken,
ob er so schnell noch einen Ausbildungsplatz bekommt.
Da hätte er eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, also das ist ja Azubi-Knappheit in Deutschland, oder?
Ich weiß nicht genau, das ist ja auch unser Beitrag hier zum Wirtschaftsstandort,
dass wir sagen, wer von dieser Lazy Gen Z jetzt endlich mal eine Ausbildung
anfängt und mal ein bisschen arbeitet für sein Geld,
darf einen Tag kommen.
Wer für kein Geld arbeiten will, das ist erstmal das Azubi-Leben, mein Freund.
Lehrjahre sind keine Herrenjahre, kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Das ist limitierte Anzahl an Tickets gibt's und das ist nur am 29.12.
Dritter, also für den 27.28.
Ihr habt da keine Ausrede, müsst ihr noch bei den Eltern sitzen und euch erklären
lassen, wie wichtig eine Ausbildung ist.
Einfach nochmal die Geschenke nochmal austragen.
Ich will zum Kongress, Alter. Ich mach diese Scheiß-Päcker-Ausbildung.
Ich muss abhauen, Sofía, weh.
Staatlich geprüfter Hacker.
Ich bin scheiße. Bäcker. Nein, Hacker, Mama. Hacker.
Das sind die, die nicht so früh aufstehen müssen.
Du musst morgens in die Hackerei. Nicht in die Bäckerei.
Morgens in der Hackerei. In der Weihnacht. Okay.
Oh Mann. Den Ohrwurm kriegen die Leute jetzt nicht raus, ist klar, ne?
Ja, das soll jetzt aber ehrlich auch den Titel.
Rolf Harkowski. Okay.
Ja, Leute, ich glaube, das war es jetzt erstmal wieder mit der Sendung.
Geht mal arbeiten.
Tut mal was für euer Geld.
Was ihr nicht kriegt. Für den Wirtschaftsstandort.
Wie soll sich das Kapital hier sonst mehren, wenn ihr da nicht mit anfasst?
Ja, Kapitalismus ist gut für euch.
Ja.
Das war's, oder? Mehr Witze fallen mir jetzt nicht ein.
Über Ausbildung?
Nee, generell so, meine ich.
Ja. Ich hatte letztens noch ein lustiger Witz eingefallen.
Wir denken uns fürs nächste Mal einen Witz aus.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Wir müssen uns ja vorher die ganzen Witze für die Sendung über ausdenken.
Vorher können wir gar nicht erst anfangen.
Ja. Ich will auch übrigens hier genau, ich will diesen Khaleesi-Klingelton haben
hier für mein Soundboard Genau.
Einfach hier Wer hat das gemacht? Wer war das? Markus Ja, schick mal rüber Sonst
musst du dir das noch selber rausschneiden Vielleicht hast du ja die beste Stelle schon entdeckt Achso.
Er hat übrigens auch noch gesagt ihr seid große Klasse Habe ich vergessen Ihr
seid große Klasse Hat er sogar richtig geschrieben, weil häufig schreiben Leute das falsch.
Wie denn?
Ich sehe, also es gibt zwei Fehler, kann ich noch kurz sagen,
es gibt zwei Fehler, die mich wirklich...
Jenseits der Datumsnotation?
Genau, falsche Datumsnotation, Leerzeichen in der Teilnahme.
Ja, kann man anders sehen.
Das, das und seit, seit. Also das mit ein S und zwei S.
Ja.
Das kann ich nicht akzeptieren, diesen Fehler. Und seit und seit.
Dann bei dem Fehler antworte ich gerne mal seit wann?
Auf welche Frage?
Na, wenn jemand den seit Fehler macht. Also in diesem Fall wäre es,
es hat er nicht gemacht, aber wenn jetzt ihr seid große Klasse,
seit mit T geschrieben worden wäre, dann wäre meine Antwort darauf, seid mit D wann?
Ja, ich bin halt Lehrer, kennt was.
Ja, ja, Lehrer kennt man, kennt auch. Bisschen überheblich.
Ich verkneife mir das ja schon. Aber das sind die Sachen.
Ich verkneife mir das, aber ich erzähle das einfach mal im Podcast.
Seit, seit, dass das falsche Datumsnotation, Leerzeichen, Dateinamen, was noch?
No judging jetzt hier.
Ach so, und Rassismus.
Damit kannst du mich jagen.
Aber sonst bin ich eigentlich ganz umgekehrt.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich merke das jedes Mal wieder hier. Total. Ich kann mich verbürgen.
So Leute, tschüss. Das war's.